[Música]
nos la da su vuelo
la mirada en el trayecto largo y el paso
lento acompasado aclaró el beso a la
canción flotar se posa en los cuerpos
vamos a lincoln
va manejando no sé el tiempo el
metrónomo que ya está la sangre todo el
cuerpo en regiones en este momento no ha
dejado tan verde
ha vuelto
y complicidad
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
ah
hay que trabajo me cuesta
[Música]
quererte como
te quiero
por tu amor me duele el aire
el corazón
sombrero
bien
i
y
la risa la complicidad del espacio y el
tiempo en el que coincidimos la risa de
nuevo deseos pendiente los sueños
cumplidos la voz que los más es del
fondo del río y arrastra consigo las
ramas de un árbol que no soportaba más
peso hacia el dolor que las beso se pasa
el dolor que las dice que no
comprendimos el viento las veces que
agradecimos de veras que soplará fuerte
las velas de nuestro barquito para que
siguiera donde fuera mi gran compañera
mi niña mi casa que abraza y abraza
porque es una hoguera que cuando sonríe
en la primavera los ojos que saben leer
y los brazos dispuestos a saber la
historia una noria de versos o de este
maestro para saber qué silencios de ocho
redonda cuidar la canción cuidarnos del
miedo dejar que nos crezca el amor en el
pecho y dejarnos salir sin poner el
horario que en un escenario se siente la
tempestad es conmigo estoy en ti y la
verdad no necesita de más adornos sigue
el contorno del porvenir estoy con
o estás en mí yo estoy en la verdad
demás adornos sigue el contorno del
porvenir estoy contigo estás me encantó
armar una noche de verano improvisar
nada cómo hacer que lorca viaje en la
brisa
nada
[Música]
ah
es conmigo estoy en ti y la verdad no
necesidad de más adorno sigue el
contorno de porvenir estoy contigo estoy
contigo está estoy contigo estás en mí y
la verdad no necesidad de más adornos
sigue el contorno del porvenir estoy
contigo estás en mí
[Música]
la guitarra que presenta trae canciones
del norte es un medio de transporte
mucho más con instrumentos para mimar un
momento como el tiempo es reducido
traten de acercarse oído al pecho de las
canciones si bailan sus corazones habrá
tenido sentido
[Música]
puerta no sé la noche
el día no quiere
y trato
en este lugar
cromático y sin más descrito el aire que
me falta hoy vendrá y traerá consigo el
canto a pleno pulmón la ocasión de
vibrar
y sanar por dentro y viene la luz viene
de arusha trepando poco a poco hasta
subirse en la mañana y te da la luz se
ve desde el espacio toda tu carita no se
va la luz
pero casi no se nota por el brillo en la
mirada y se va la luz se va la luz pero
el amor
sean malas
[Música]
pero el amor nunca sea
la lluvia no cesa pensar en el silencio
pienso en el tiempo que hace que yo
salgo a bailar quiero gritar
a soltar
el medio y hacer minúsculo este miedo al
fin porque todo el aire que me falta hoy
vendrá para consigo el canto a pleno
pulmón la ocasión de vibrar
y sanar porque viene la luz viene la luz
va trepando poco a poco hasta subirse a
la mañana y te da la luz de dar a luz y
se ve desde el espacio todas sus caritas
guapas se va la luz se va la luz yo casi
no se nota el por el brillo la mirada se
va la luz se va la luz
[Música]
el amor nunca
chiapas
[Música]
el amor
ah
[Aplausos]
si tienes
[Música]
bueno ahora nos gustaría
que se imaginarán a un pequeñín gateando
por aquí y ese pequeñín se llama luca y
nosotros vamos a cantarle a intentar
animarles e invitarle a que sea
completamente libre siempre ya que sé a
quien quiere hacer así que nada truco
brillará la noche segura y ahora música
empáticos imagino que ocurrió el paladín
de la ternura sin temer que la aventura
algo le desequilibra lo que importará es
que vibre y su piel le indica el norte
el amor será el resort de que le impulsa
que ser libre toluca
e
y
lugar
el nombre del niño niña planta piña o
pez será es lo que te plazca en morder
tus pies no debajo de la manta
cantaremos para hacer bailar a nuestros
fantasmas
[Música]
loca
querrás colgar en los árboles hacer
valer o hablar de naves espaciales
viendo las paredes de la habitación o
andar descansan por el cielo en lo bueno
a pesar de juguemos al avión
m
bien
[Música]
y no quiero que llegue es el primero a
ningún lugar quiero que tengas el
corazón contento ya está de nuevo
jaja y yo no quiero que compiten por ser
la mejor quiero que tengas bien
calentito el corazón que reparta se el
calor sea así
[Música]
local
y cuando te duela el mundo
mientras un patito
con unas casas juntas canciones de jorge
drexler no estará sola en tu dolor con
la duda si es muda tu preocupación no
haremos más preguntas debería hablar con
el mar te enseñaré bien
y nunca se acaba de pensar a comprender
la vida no quiero que des el primero a
ningún lugar quiero que tengas el
corazón contento
kaká de nuevo jajaja yo no quiero que
combinas por ser el mejor quiero que
tengas en cada sentido el corazón y
repartos el calor sea es libre
con libreta
decidir a quién besa libre para preferir
montaña amarla
escoger no tener que elegir libre para
hacerte
[Música]
ah
o no
[Música]
velocidad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]